I'M A WELCOME TO THE JANUARY
FIFTEENTH MEETING OF INSURANCE
SO TODAY WE HAVE ONE BILL TO
HERE SO WE CAN ALL GET OUT HERE
AS- SOON AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR. UP TO THIS
COMMITTEE. ARE WE YOU DON'T A
QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA START AS
MANY AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
ONE BILL TO PRESENT AND I WOULD
BE SB SEVEN FIFTY I'VE BY
MYSELF SO I'M GONNA ASK MISTER
ROB. YOU MINE NUMBER THE
GOVERNMENT. I'M SURE
. ONCE
AGAIN GOOD MORNING. SO. I DO
AGREE TO TAKE THE MEN MEN
SUGGESTED BY THE ANALYSIS ON SB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE AT FIFTY SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR I WOULD PROVIDE SOME
HELP TO HOMEOWNERS PURCHASED
POLICY OVER THE PHONE OR ONLINE
AND THEIR NON RENEWED BY THEIR
INSURERS. BUT MOST ENSURE
FILTERING UP. BY THE CUSTOMER
AVAILABLE ALTERNATIVE SOURCES
OF COVERAGE FOR INSURANCE
INCLUDING TO THE FAIR PLAN AND
SURPLUS LINE BROKERS. SB SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE EXPAND THE
APPLICABLE ANY OF THE NOTICE
TO- SO INSURERS THAT DO NOT
SELL POLICY SIR AGENTS OR
BROKERS MUST ALSO PROVIDE THIS
NOTICE WHEN IT NON RENEWED.
SIMMERS IN ADDITION TO NOTIFY
CUSTOMERS OF THE FAIR AND
SURPLUS LINES BROKERS
INFORMATION FOR OTHER INSURERS
THAT TRANSACTING SHARON'S TO
AGENTS OR BROKERS WILL ALSO BE
PROVED. ON THE NEW. ACTING
CONSUMERS WITH THE COVERAGE
THEY NEED CRITICAL TO STABILIZE
IN THE INSURANCE MARKET SB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE. WILL MAKE
SURE CUSTOMERS GET THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION
REGARDLESS OF HOW THE INSURANCE
COMPANY SELLS ITS PRODUCTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB SEVEN FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU. AND LET'S SERVE.
CALL THE ROLL MISTER WHICH FORM
MA'AM SECTOR RUBIO. PRESENT
YOUR PRESENT JOB. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA PRESENT BATES BOARD
YES. PRESENT DODD JOHNNY GLAZER
PLEASE ARE PRESENT HUESO
MITCHELL MITCHELL PRESENT MORE
LOCK. RESIDENT PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO PRESENT ROSTER
PRESENT. WE HAVE A QUORUM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I'M ANNA
BUCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE WITNESS IS IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. PUBLIC
COMMENT. TING NONE QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS MEMBERS. AND
MOVED. THERE ARE TWO OTHER.
THANK YOU. FOR IBM FIRED BACK
THAT ONLY HOMEOWNER. WILL THAT
WORK I ACTUALLY FAMILY. LOS
MENU IT WILL WORK. HAVEN'T
PEOPLE OFF. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL OPEN THE DOOR TO ALLOW.
RESIDENT IS THERE. THE THAT AND
WE'RE BUT CERTAINLY ALL THE WAY
AROUND THE- NO ONE MYERS. HELLO.
HELLO BUT TO ALLOW EVERYONE
HAVE A PORTABLE. THAT THE- YOU.
AND. IN YOUR RESEARCH. YEAH. WE
ALWAYS WANT TO DEFINITELY GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPTION I AM SORRY
THE INFORMATION AT THEIR
FINGERTIPS IN CASE THEY NEED
THAT THAT THAT SUPPORT AND SO
THIS IS JUST AN EXTRA LAYER OF
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS AND
KIDS ARE NOT RENEWED IT'S-
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THEM TO. PICK
UP. PERRANCE ALSO ARE. YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A MOTION YEAH. RUBIO
AYE AYE JONES ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA AYE BATES BRIDGES. OR
JUST AYE DODD NOT YOUNG DODD I.
GALGIANI GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HUESO MITCHELL. MITCHELL AYE
MORLOCK FOR LIKE I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE. NINE
AND WE SEVERAL AND JOHN. WE
HAVE NINE VOTES SERVICE VISUAL
HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANKS VERY MUCH
MANAGER. THANK YOU. RIGHT
. FOR
PRESIDING DURING MY BILL
PRESENTATION AT THIS POINT
WE'RE JUST GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M
SORRY BEST GALGIANI. SB SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED CURRENT THAT IS NINE
ZERO GALGIANI. GALGIANI I. THE
VOTE IS TEN ZERO. AND I'M JUST
HOLDING THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MITCHELL SO IF HE'S HEARING-
WE'RE GONNA WAIT HERE FOR
ANOTHER TEN MINUTES AND- I'LL
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE COME WHO WILL HOLD THE
WRONG. YEAH
. OPENING THE ROLE
FOR SB SEVEN FIFTY FIVE MISTER
WITH SOME. I HUESO I. THE VOTE
IS OUT ELEVEN ZERO. AND THIS
CONCLUDES THANK YOU